i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council in the data community fund
and we've been pleased to be able to
bring you these
programs um almost every week
we typically have a great open source
leader in the data community and or the
founder of a tech startup in the data
ecosystem
and we're super excited today to have
another great guest on the show
it's will falcon who is the co-founder
and ceo of grid
which is a new company that's popped up
in the deep learning ecosystem
uh will is known probably most recently
for
being the the core author of pi torch
lightning
which is an open source deep learning
framework and
we'll um you have a pretty interesting
past so i'm just going to like list a
few things and then
you can tell us a little bit about how
those things do or don't fit into data
so you were previously a researcher at
facebook ai research
and a phd student under yon lacun at nyu
but before that you worked at a bunch of
different startups
you co-founded a startup called next-gen
vest you're a software engineer at
goldman sachs
and in a previous life before that
you're a captain in the air force
and you also trained as a navy seal so
um let's start with the navy seal stuff
first because that's most interesting
and probably the biggest outlier
um how did how did that happen and how
did you get from being a navy seal
um and going ultimately ending up at
facebook ai research
yeah um all great questions so first of
all thanks for having me pete so
always excited to to chat with you um
yeah you know like i think um from a
really young age
i always you know i grew up in latin
america and
there's a lot of stuff that happens that
you're exposed to there right so in
venezuela specifically and
i was always passionate about trying to
figure out how to make a difference
there
and you know when i was in high school
kind of the thing that was top of mind
for me was you know at least a thing
that was accessible to me to be able to
make a difference with the military
and that was at a time when like you
know iraq and afghanistan all these
things were happening and
i thought that the the most relevant way
to get involved and like
you know have a positive impact uh you
know us
you know whatever your political views
aside are um you know as a
as a high schooler uh with you know some
so many limited options these are some
of the things that we think that we can
do really well
and um i thought that the seal teams
were
you know at the right place at the right
time they were helping
in in key areas um especially in latin
america as well and so i was really
drawn to it
so i so i joined the navy and i started
going through seal training
and you know so training is like a very
long process
uh so i was there for a while and i
fortunately got injured a few times
and this was happened to coincide with
the time and uh
in the military where they were
downsizing um with
you know pulling out of iraq and all
these different things and so
basically administratively if you hadn't
finished training which was me
and you were still around which is many
years of training
then they were like okay do you want to
be an intel officer or do you want to
fly planes or do you want to get out and
i was like okay
well i came here to be a ceo so like i
guess if that's not gonna happen then
i'm gonna get out and do something else
so um but it was you know i was there
for
about four years active and then two
years reserve and
learned a lot right um spent some time
with one of the seal teams
um learning what they do downrange and
uh working alongside them
in an intel capacity and yeah it just
changes your perspective a lot on
you know what's possible what isn't and
you know
stress stress um i guess levels out
sets a really high bar for that maybe
some um some unexpected but interesting
lessons
towards being becoming a startup founder
later on
yeah i mean there are a lot of parallels
right like i think the biggest thing
that you learn in seal training
is to just roll with the punches like
you know
you show up every single day you don't
have you don't know what you're going to
do
i mean you kind of know generally but
you don't really know
um you're not allowed to have watches
you don't know any concept of time or
anything
so no one controls your day like they
control your day
and so you just have to show up and then
you know imagine imagine
when you go work out today you're like
you're ready for a run and you're like
okay i'm gonna do a three mile run
and you know how about how that's gonna
be imagine if for like
six months every every time you showed
up somewhere you didn't know what you
were gonna do i'm like literally it
could be like
you just start running and then you're
like are we doing a two mile or ten mile
run
you don't know you don't know until
you're done right and
are we sprinting or not it doesn't
matter right so what that teaches you is
literally just roll with the punches at
every single moment like it does not
matter what's happening you just
go and do it right and that's that is
the key to startup worlds right it's the
ability to
on a dime pivot or switch or be okay
with complete uncertainty and
you know that's one aspect of it and to
do it everywhere um
you know they simulate like combat they
simulate a lot of stuff like that as
well and
and then when you're actually working
with the teams like these things happen
very dynamically right so that these are
very dynamic environments so
yeah a lot of lessons that's uh that's
really incredible
insight and i can see how that can be
applied to some of what you're
doing today so were you and were you
technically inclined at the time
um when did engineering and cs and stuff
sort of you know come into your career
yeah so i wasn't i mean that never coded
didn't even know you i mean i guess i
knew you could code i thought a thing
but like i didn't know who did that
i i definitely didn't um and i you know
i
i didn't really have a lot of math
background either i think i had the
just standard high school algebra but i
never you know in
high school i was training to be a ceo
so like i wasn't focused on academia or
anything
um and so not really i think um what
happened is
you know i was planning doing 20 years
in the in the teal teams and
when i left i was like okay well what am
i going to do now right like that's
kind of out of the window and um and i
got into finance i had been working
i don't know why like from from a very
young age i really liked trading stocks
so i like knew like
a weirdly like a weird amount of i had a
weird amount of knowledge on this
and i ended up working in finance and
during that process i i was like man
i feel like i was doing repetitive work
over and over again and so
i started trying to figure out how to
automate this i like i think it was like
vba the first thing i started trying to
do
on that side and then i started looking
at java and then objective c
and then that led me to iphone apps and
then i was like oh this is cool and then
i just really got into it it was like my
night and
like nights and weekends like that's
what i was doing all nights and weekends
um and then just kind of picked it up
that way and then once i got to uh to
columbia for my undergrad then
that's when i i really focused on it got
it
got it and then was one of your early
jobs out of
columbia was that when you went to
goldman and run the software engineering
team there
yeah yeah so that was uh that's a very
interesting story
so i was i was building apps i was
consulting and
you know i was trying to like launch
startups right so i mean i think like we
had this chat like a year ago or two
years ago i think
um we were on this panel and they were
like oh you know next year invest worked
out and
i i don't think i'd started grid yet and
then um i was like yeah but you know
like
there are like 12 other things that
failed that like never made it to
be anything like how many how many dead
web apps
were there how many iphone apps that i
try to launch you know
and so that's what i was doing during
that period was building things
launching them seeing what happened
learn a ton right learn a lot um
and and you know one of those apps i
launched actually took off and it was
it was something to like unfriend people
on facebook using like a tinder
swipe so you load this app and then you
could just like swipe left and right
so that took off and then um yeah that
was an interesting app
and then and then um and then
you know from there i ended up getting
kind of started getting recruited by
facebook
um and then um and then friends at
goldman saw it
and then you know had a great i guess it
was good timing
and then um ended up taking a job at
goldman
um doing that but i wasn't really
looking for a job because i was still in
school
and so i took the job because it was
like hey come work at the startup
i know what a startup is now but you
know it's as close as you're gonna get
in finance
um it's this team called marquis which
is uh really cool if you go into goldman
and they build you know a lot of new
products and then they launch them they
spin them off and do their own things
and and so i got there and i was like
startup people who are like trying to
build like trying to move at that pace
inside a bank which is hard to do but
you know they were doing their best
and um i was still in school though but
i was doing part-time because i was
still studying machine learning
so technically never left during that
period but you know figured it out i
guess
wild um such a such a colorful past
um and so then you're you're building
iphone apps
um you started to sort of explore you
know like
real career jobs at in finance
facebook was sort of interested also how
did you sort of get pushed
um you know deeper into the data science
machine learning
ultimately deep learning track when did
that start to
i happen it was around goldman so i had
when i
when i started at columbia i started cs
but after my first semester i switched
i had i switched to stats and uh cs and
then
later on math as well and mostly because
i was more interested in the math so i
was already doing a lot of statistics
machine learning that kind of stuff
before i got to goldman
um but i wasn't doing it professionally
so once i got there
and i started thinking about it you know
our teams did a lot of
algorithmic trading and like systematic
trading strategies but
at that point they weren't really using
a lot of machine learning it was mostly
just math like a lot of the finance
stuff uses like ffts and these different
things
um which which is cool but i was like
hey i want to use deep learning
and at that time frame the bank
maybe they're ready now but the bank
back then wasn't ready i think mostly
from
regulation like they were you know like
neural networks are
black boxes i don't think they are
really that much but
um at least in finance it's it's a
little bit hard to explain why something
happens
so that was like the big hangout for
them and um so i understood that there
was like a timing issue there so i got
into it
aggressively then so i pushed for the
time that i was there
and then when i basically was blocked
and couldn't get anywhere i left and
then i started
um like my company so um and then you
know
at that point like i met my co-founder
and she was
um she was working on like an earlier
version of of this of next channel
right so he had been doing it for about
two years trying to get like
educational material sold and a few
other things and
then we started chatting about oh can we
help these people like over sms
you know scale up the you know how do we
do financial advice
over over sms and so we kind of pivoted
towards that
and ended up building the company off of
that after that
and one of your talks yeah yeah
um so this is next-gen best which which
was providing financial advice for
students as i recall right
so was this was this partly like to
scratch your own itch like you wanted to
use
deep did next year invest use deep
learning um
in some way so that this was your
opportunity to start your own company
build a product and sort of integrate
this tech that you
wanted to use in in a more formal career
but um didn't really have the
opportunity to in finance
i mean that was one aspect but the other
aspect was
that i had also been you know had just
come from
transitioning from the military into
into colombia and i'd seen
the opportunity gap right so i showed up
to colombia and all these people have
had
so much training and schooling before
they even got there and i was like okay
well
this sucks so how do we give that access
to other people
so i was thinking about that and then i
was also thinking about
accessible finance so goldman like why
why isn't um
why something like banking for gen z
right like younger people like why are
they
like what what products are going to be
rolled out for them right so we were
thinking about that and then kelly was
thinking about that as well
and um and then when we coupled that
with machine learning and deep learning
we found a way to scale that up
right and so that's really what what we
did with uh with next-gen best was
scale of financial advice over text
message
um and it was early stage it was like
early nlp it was pre-birth
right so it was like a year or two
before burke where we were using like
seek to seek models and
um like um what do you call them siamese
networks that kind of stuff
to do a lot of this i think the models
work a lot better today for using
transformers of course
um but back then you know we were able
to give you real-time
predictions on what you should say next
to two people
coming in right so we had at a peak i
think we had about 65 000 users
um and then we only had like maybe
40 we call the money mentors uh across
the us
that were helping scale up the advice to
those people which is a lot because they
were
we would have thousands of chats a day
so we were basically human in the loop
but
being able to answer faster because of
the deep learning
and then you know once we got acquired i
think they've grown
massively after that uh so you know
curious to see how they've scaled
and what about the the data challenge
that a lot of startups face where
they don't really have enough data to
science like how did you
how did you train your models and how
did you like what was there a critical
mass that when you sort of had enough
users and enough
training data to really make these these
uh algos work or
how did you solve that problem or think
about that at the time
so nowadays you can use transfer
learning especially for nlp right
transfer learning from feedback then
didn't work you couldn't do that
so we actually we were i mean
we basically ran the thing with that
machine learning for like two three
months to start getting enough
messages right and then once we had that
then
we could trade models right but we had
to like basically run with that models
for a while
um so you could you can solve it that
way it's just like
you know paid there's just like human
human in the loop human in the loop sort
of
curating the messages back and just
doing it manually until you had enough
enough of a trading set to train them
yeah so if i were to do it today i'd
take a pre-trained model
um like a gpt or something and then and
then collect enough data
the thing that you can do today is you
don't need to collect data for three
months right you can just do it for a
few weeks probably and get it and get
and then fine tune on that and you'll
probably get pretty good results
got it so so that was the next gen best
story and then
um you decided to go get a phd at nyu
um did facebook was facebook sort of
mixed in
in there because you ultimately ended up
working at fair as well right
yeah so facebook was not mixed in there
um i mean nyu has a very
really close relationship with facebook
uh because and then
basically most of the professors in that
lab have some at some point been
research scientists on facebook
uh at fair and um but no that wasn't
that wasn't it so i had applied to phds
and you know when i applied i was still
with nexembest right so we were like
okay um we hadn't been acquired yet and
so we were thinking about the next stage
of the company and i was like well
we're gonna submit the applications and
then see where we go from there right
and then
i got accepted to a few programs um
but also nyu and nyu was in new york
you know actually two blocks away from
the next gen vest office
so so one but second i mean one of my
favorite researchers
around ever is kyung hincho and chose
one of my
my advisors and i mean you know when i
when i see his career i feel like he's
taking that same path that like jan and
joshua took many years ago and like i
think we'll see a lot
i mean he's already done a lot for the
field but i think you know he's just
getting started he's very early career
and so i was really excited to work with
him and so i got an offer to work with
him
and then at the time i hadn't started
working with yon yet
and um i was like yeah this sounds
amazing so i took the offer
and then basically by luck we got
acquired
during that summer and then i was like
oh great
so we're going to make this happen um
and so
you know we had that we had the decision
of like do we got to acquire do we want
to race the next round
um but i think at the time we thought
that partnering with
the choir made a lot of more sense in
terms of like being able to go into the
next stage of the company
so so the timing was right and so i
started phd uh with kyunghan
specifically
and then um after about my first year
like when i started i was working on
yeah i was working on more nlp again so
because that's all i've been doing for a
while nlp
and then started working on audio and
then um
that summer i interned at fair so that's
how
i got into fair um and my i started
doing internship with
with kyung hyun and then after that we
started working with jan as well right
so mostly because my research took a
turn towards
self-supervised learning and i mean i
think jan's obviously one of the best
people in the world at this
and you know i think like we have very
similar well
i buy a lot of his views on subscribers
learning and i've like since developed
some of my own as well and
and so um we started working together at
that point and then um
and so then i sit on a fair as a phd
researcher so continue doing research
both at nyu unfair um and uh
yeah then that's when lightning was
happening during all of us
right so i mean like lightning started
really like um when i was an undergrad
at columbia like and i was doing
research
i had you know i was i had like when i
so there was a gap between goldman and
next investor i was doing where i got
back into research
well where i started doing research and
that was you know after being a
professional software engineer i was
like okay how do i move through this
stuff quickly and i started coding
a lot of like i was i was using
tensorflow back then a lot of stuff in
tensorflow like to be able to like
the main problem i was trying to solve
was like if i have an idea how do i
iterate how do i create a new idea
quickly without having to copy my code
over and over again right so
if you do deep learning today you're
like you create a file you have your
idea there
you're training train train you want to
train a new idea you copy that file
again and then now you have your other
idea and then you modify it
and then three months later those are
out of sync you know and like now you're
maintaining two code bases it's a mess
so i was trying to solve that problem
back then wasn't quite getting it
um and then and then you know continued
when we started next genves like
we went the full production route on
tensorflow so they didn't really
do a lot of lightning stuff there it was
mostly just like production tensorflow
wasn't training a lot
um and then um so once i got well once
next
invest left and then we got now i got
back into nyu
then i was like wait let me dust up this
uh project you know and like see if i
can get this thing to work again
and so um so then i rewrote the that
what i had before into what is now
lightning well the early versions of
that
uh still still quite didn't get it right
and then
basically like in the spring before i
joined fair
i got the last abstractions which are
like the trainer lighting module all
that
and then i open sourced it and then join
facebook and then um
and then after that it's where it got
its distributed capabilities
so you are essentially trying to solve
this i guess it's called the glue code
problem
where um if you're building stuff
sort of around the tens some people
prefer to call tensorflow library maybe
not even a framework
you're sort of building stuff around
tensorflow and
um it's hard to sort of understand the
distinction sometimes between the
implementation code the the glue code
and the model
itself um and so you were essentially
trying to solve
this this type of problem through these
projects that ultimately sort of
pivoted into lightning it sounds like
yeah exactly because
like i i knew i started to see the
pattern so i was like oh i i know i'm
repeating the code but like
i'm not sure what and like if you know
what what i was scared of is like if i
start abstracting stuff away am i going
to limit
what i can do later right so it wasn't
obvious what i should abstract and so
that's why it took like
around four years to figure that out and
the lightning api you see today is
something where
you know very comfortably you're not
going to be locked into anything because
it is very flexible because
you know we did think about this for a
long time
and then and so as a researcher i need
ultimate flexibility i can't go into a
framework and then
you know buy into it spend six months
working on it
then i want to try something and
suddenly it's impossible and i'm like
[ __ ] i just wasted six months right so
that was what i wanted to wear with
lightning and um and it's also why i
didn't push it too hard in the beginning
because i was still unclear if that
could happen right so
you know when i open source it i didn't
really announce it like you can
you know look at the repo like it was
there but like i wasn't talking about it
because it was my own project
um when i got to facebook and other
people started using it at fair
then i was like oh interesting okay well
yeah let me see can you do your work on
this without getting limitations
and you know they did run into
limitations for a few months and we
fixed them we got rid of them
um to the point where like around august
i was like huh
turns out that like you can do vision
you can do nlp you can do audio like
none of this stuff is blocked
so yeah i guess it's getting more
general and uh we're at the point now
where it is pretty general like you can
do rl you can do graph networks you can
do whatever like i don't think people
have run into something you can't do
with lightning yet
um and if they do like we'll fix it
pretty quickly
so and can you just so that our our
listeners understand and so i understand
um can you
explain the relationship between
lightning and pi torch
um like what what do those interfaces
look like and
what are the correct abstractions to
think of there yeah for sure so
i would consider pi torch like kind of
equivalent to numpy
right so you have raw tensors and you do
operations in those you also have
autograd so pytorch is like autograd
and numpy but like you know like a very
high speed
accelerated version of numpy so that
that's what pie touch gives you the raw
ingredients right so for example
why does scale earn exist because how
many times did you take the same svm and
coded a numpy
it's just boilerplate right so there
needed to be an abstraction on top of
that
so pytorch gives you those components
but it doesn't really structure your
code it doesn't really give you the
higher level structure it gives you
layers and that kind of stuff
but it doesn't really let you figure out
how to put them together right so you
still have to figure that out
um so it gives you ultimate flexibility
but with
you know so always a trade-off with
ultimate flexibility you also get code
that is not easily deployable
you also get code that is not easily
shareable
you also get code that's you know has a
high um
like capacity for bugs because there's a
lot of code like a lot of surface area
to touch
and so it's a trade-off right so you get
to move faster ideas but
maybe you can't deploy them quickly so
that's a problem so
lightning basically says okay well let
me remove all the spoiler plate
which you're going to repeat project the
project and let you focus just on the
code that's going to change between
projects which is the computational
stuff
and then how the how models interact
with each other so
it abstracts away all that stuff um and
it wasn't obvious
like i said what to abstract away like
you know was the optimizer supposed to
be objective like
you know we didn't know that um but we
figured it out
and we're still learning what what could
be in is not abstractable
right um we'll abstract something and
someone's like oh i can't do this now
we're like okay too much
put it back right so so lightning is
you can think about lighting it's just
um it's it's literally like um
like a style guide for by torch
basically
so again you're it's like a hardness
you're just writing pytorch but you're
implementing an interface right so you
have a method you write your code
you have another method you write your
code and that's it but by that structure
you get to remove like 90 of your
boilerplate and then you get to scale
out
across whatever hardware you want across
all the clusters whatever you
whatever computational needs you have
and it also lets us embed like
all the engineering best practices so
lightning has over 400 contributors
today
from you know fair google there's
yeah there's definitely google people
there um like microsoft
i mean everywhere top companies top
research labs people who are putting
their code in there
um because they use it right and they
use it for stuff they could use it for
research production doesn't matter
but you're getting the collective
knowledge of everyone so you know like
basically you're not going to mess up
the simple things that like
you know the way you write your for loop
and pytorch might be slower versus like
a super experienced engineer who knows
how to do that much faster
so you get those benefits while
maintaining control
got it and so um
how did the adoption go from um you know
where it is now
sort of walking backwards from these
early days at fair you you saw
you brought so basically you brought
this open source tool um into your job
at fair
um you know your probably started to use
it you guys started to improve it
um like what was the next sort of hurdle
like in traction
adoption that you saw happen like when
did you have an aha moment that
um sort of the rest of the world would
would maybe start to use this as well
i mean you know i don't think there's
like a a silver bullet for adoption
right that's
that's what uh everyone's you know we're
all looking for that what's that answer
like oh
these seven words will get you adoption
i don't think that exists like what
what exists is you know hours of coding
and taking every single feature and
every bug and implementing it as fast as
possible as best as you can
testing your code giving people
tutorials and examples
and it's just a grind grind hard for
many many many months
right like that's just what it is so
either you're willing to put in the
effort you're not
so what what drove the adoption is like
i have
very high capacity for output and so
yeah i was coding non-stop for like a
year
right and it wasn't just me but it was
like 10 other amazing core contributors
who
just dedicated their time to making this
and improving it so
you had you know 10 11 people around the
clock working on this stuff
not and dedicated not to mention the
other
you know 200 people that stopped by fix
a bug here and there
did whatever small contributions so you
know by sheer will i guess
and force so the community started to
discover it more people started to jump
on board
um were you giving conference talks
about it or
um how did it sort of pop up in the wild
outside of facebook
i mean we would do tutorials and stuff
right so people started using it but
i think the key is when something is
useful to people
they will drive that option right that's
the key like if if it's something that
you can use
and then you will go ahead and create
your own stuff and you'll create your
own you'll enter in competitions you'll
carry your own tutorials
i mean like you we've all done this we
all run some into such a cool tool that
we're like man i really want to tell
people like how awesome is this thing
and you write something about it right
so it's a little catch-22 like i guess
i would say focus on the product focus
on the um
building something that people love and
then
you know the growth will come i guess
well that's definitely the yc model
isn't it um
build something that people love and uh
and that that usually wins the day
in the long run um but still at the same
time
there there are tactical things that
teams do and end up doing to increase
adoption and to
you know establish feedback loops with
their users and
you know there's other tactical things
in the distribution side that
that happen whether they're intentional
or not sometimes they're not intentional
in the community just pick something up
but
um yes it's interesting to hear your
thoughts on
obviously the importance of of the the
product and the
and the usability of the thing itself
which is um
of course i i wouldn't disagree with
yeah but you i mean you bring a good
point is the the tight feedback loops
right if someone submits a bug and you
wait two months to implement like people
are going to have this interest right
yeah for sure um when did the core contr
so did the core contributors around the
project sort of
grow in step with just the overall
interest in the project
um i'm sure you started to see
you know pull requests pop up from orgs
that you didn't necessarily know were
using
lightning did you have to nurture those
contributors in any special way
yeah i mean i think you always have to
understand contributors right so
you i think part of the job is to allow
people to contribute as much as they can
right like you should facilitate that
through process documentation all of it
right your builds
the speed of the build everything else
so
i think it's also clear when like people
are really into a project you'll see
their behavior
you know they're submitting prs left and
right they're super active and like
i think those are awesome candidates to
start working with and you start working
closely and like the way the lightning
works is
you know we we see your behavior we look
at your code and we think you're a good
engineer
and then we kind of let you do that for
a little bit see if you continue and if
you do then we'll put you into like a
like a tryout period basically um which
will last
you know multiple months and if you uh
if you make it through that
um and if we still like you then you
know we all decide if we want to take
you on board core or not
and this is uh this is sort of the the
recruiting
process for the the pie charts project
you're talking about or the the
lightning project sorry
yeah and like i mean a few of our
sundown grid
so we have a bunch of those core people
who are not full-time employees right
so they're working full-time on
lightning as well
well this is an interesting you know
transition and
um i think it you're right it speaks to
the power of
having a community um around an open
source project
because um not only you know does that
community sort of become self-sustaining
and makes the project better but
um as you as the visionary or a
visionary behind the project want to
continue to
to push the envelope and do bigger
things
sometimes those folks can can be
recruited into bigger ideas
um so so tell us how that transition
happened
um when did you realize that like at
what moment
did it become obvious to you that there
might be a company to start here around
this open source project
yeah i think people are asking for a lot
of features that it was just impossible
to build on the open source
and you needed other stuff right more
like collaboration and that kind of
thing and so
yeah that can basically live in a
product and for a while i was like
how do i build this in such a way that
people can benefit from it but
at the end of the day like you know this
is something that companies use
labs you know individuals all these
people and
um it's it's they won't use it
if it's not backed by a formal company
right and they won't use it if there's
no full-time support and full-time
employees
so you get into this kind of catch-22 as
well because you want people to adopt
but they're like well
like are you a random project like i
don't know right so
so then that's the point where you know
we fundraised and the money went really
towards that right is to hire the people
to be able to build the tools for the
community so i mean grid is building
tools for our community
um and then obviously the broader
community as well for machine learning
as we expand
but yeah like everything that we do in
grid
and all the features that we roll out
are driven by our community
got it and and so so i get the the
notion of having a corporate
um entity to sort of back the future
development and consistency
of the open source project did you
actually offer support
um like paid support for for lightning
or
that that you didn't necessarily go that
far
uh yeah i mean we didn't like we don't
really offer lightning support
so um support is time consuming
and draining on everyone so we uh we
give
a lot of support in slack so we help
people and the community provides a lot
of support
we have considered support for a few key
companies that we're interested in
working with
but generally yeah we haven't really
been focused on support
got it got it and and you're right and
right now like there are
thousands of companies lighting today
and you know they find they find us for
anything key
they'll ping us we'll solve the issue or
something but um generally a community
is pretty good about self
self servicing this stuff as well
and how do you measure the size of the
community or the interest
sort of the traction around lightning
like what are the main kpis that you
think are useful as a as a sort of a
instigator behind the project what do
you watch on a monthly basis
yeah i mean that's uh yeah this is
really the art of open source right
we're all trying to figure out how to
gauge that because
you know we i mean all these things are
like github stars
but github stars basically tell you
about popularity they don't tell you
anything else
um downloads i think tell you more about
adoption than anything else
like people downloading things but
downloads also hide the fact that you
know
you download something seven times a day
right or continuous integration systems
download things like 10
20 times a day so download is not a user
it's
you know some ratio um so yeah it's hard
we're always trying to estimate that
i think when you have a product with
analytics it's a lot easier but in open
source like we don't have analytics on
this stuff
yeah i tend to get excited in in in the
face of
the the weakness of those metrics that
you that you just mentioned which many
of
our are common kpis for folks um i tend
to get excited about
you know the the sort of breadth of the
contribution community i think that
sort of shows the not just the broad
appeal of a project but also
of course it's a measure of folks
willingness to contribute back which
isn't the same thing as widespread
adoption but
um to me it seems like there's something
there around
um a strong breadth or growing traction
the number of
contributors you're seeing across the
open source project but that's just
that's just one one of my uh thoughts
well that i mean that's um that's partly
that's
that's one part it's just i i do i do
agree that that's an interesting metric
but
the problem with that is that it also
depends on the code base of the product
and the project right if the thing is
super easy to contribute to yeah you're
gonna see a huge ton of contributors but
if it's complex
you're not gonna see that right so i i
don't know like i don't think that
that's really uh
it's one measure but it shouldn't be the
only one for sure
yeah well interesting to see the open
source world continue to
move forward and as more companies are
started and
more founders have these kinds of the
discussions
um you know hopefully we'll all get
smarter together about
how to quantify some of these things um
and of course the vcs want to know
the vcs want to know when the time is to
jump in and to fund that project like
do you fund based on github stars or
some other um
you know assortment of of random
statistics right
so these these are these are all
interesting questions
probably uh yeah adoption obviously but
yeah i don't know
that's a good question i mean honestly
like it's interesting because
i don't think i mean like we had what
hortonworks and then
spark hadoop those people they monetized
successfully and they became big
companies
but we haven't really seen other ones i
think from the machine learning world
that have done that right
so we've seen it in databases of course
like [ __ ] and cockroach and all these
um but we haven't seen
and then there's i guess at databricks
they've done the work as well
yeah but like we haven't i feel like
there's still a ton of room so
you know we still haven't all figured it
out and um
and you know there's like a class like
you know i call it like a class class of
20
you know 20 or 20 19 whatever it is but
we all came out and we're like around
and we're all doing stuff we're on the
same space but like
there's a big space i think like we're
all trying to collaborate and try to
figure out how to make that space bigger
and grow the pie for everyone
and so i hope that we all figured out
because we could set a good precedent
for
other people who come after us right to
figure out how to monetize as well
let's talk about that because i think
maybe
you know one of the concerns of of some
folks who watch these markets
is a more nuanced question around how
quickly is deep learning
growing and i know you faced some of
these questions
um when you were preparing to start grid
right um
how do you how do you think of the
adoption of deep learning as a
subset of overall machine learning like
how do you
sort of um explain that and
and how did you know that it was the
right time to build something that was
specifically in the deep learning
category
i mean you know i think um i don't know
if it's just new york but
i think there's always a split between
data scientists and machine learning
people right like i think when i think
about this the difference
i think about data science is really
focused on
you know like user behavior analytics
that kind of stuff
some prediction models sure but then you
have the machine learning and deep
learning people who are i think just
doing different jobs right
um and so if you speak to a data
scientist
they'll talk about regression and svms
and random forest
like that's all they need and yeah it's
probably true for what they're doing
but there's a lot of other stuff that
you can use those models for
right um that's one but second
mathematically speaking those things are
differentiable right like linear
regression's differentiable source
logistic aggression
you can approximate random force um and
you can approximate svms as well right
with gates
so you can you can use autograd i say
that because if you can use autograph
you can differentiate it's a machine
learning is a deep learning thing right
you know when we talk about deep
learning we're talking about autograd
basically
so you know like in lightning we have
linear regression logistic regression
implemented
and i can run that thing at scale and
image net on like
200 gpus right why because it's backed
by pytorch and it's backed by
a deep learning library so when i hear
about
people not going into a space or getting
too deep learning or not i'm like you're
already using it it's just you're using
it at a smaller scale
whether you call it a regression or
logistic aggression you are using it you
know you strap on three of those
legislative aggressions that's called
the three-layer neural network right
so like um so to me it's all the same
like if you're looking at it from the
math side
so i think that those people
um you know if they're not using deep
learning today like they will because
most of the top most of the
state-of-the-art models today are deep
learning now
we all of us in the deep learning world
also understand baselining right so
we're not going to build the model until
we baseline it as well because i want to
know how much better is it than
a one-layer neural network uh linear
regression a random force but there are
baselines at the end of the day
right and based on something like i used
so far um whereas with
if you know what you're doing and you
tweak your neural networks and you
increase the data you get more of the
data you're able to generate a lot more
so i think that the corporate world is a
few years behind they're catching up
hard and the ones who are
who haven't caught up are feeling that
pain because the other startups and the
other companies
are already there and that they're
they're super behind right but they will
catch up
and um and so i think like the last
holdouts there will uh will transition
pretty soon
so so so you're almost saying that
there's a maybe an
artificial separation between the notion
of
my job as a data scientist and the
notion of my job as
our potential job as a deep learning um
uh or machine learning engineer and and
you think that those things
like that wall will sort of break down
and corporate won't have
i mean i guess as you said before maybe
there's this slight stigma that you know
that that prevents people from moving
from the data science to the deep
learning camp as they they think that
deep learning is is more opaque than
maybe it is or maybe then it needs to be
um i mean i guess that might be another
sort of block that keeps them from
sort of feeling like there's a smooth
transition from one to the other but
um it sounds like you you believe
there's a lot of hope there and
and ultimately that law will be broken
down yeah i mean
i don't know what it is it's like you
know i think people i think when i speak
to
more traditional data scientists you
know there's like a point of pride in
being like oh i don't need a neural
network that's a
you know that's a hammer for what you're
trying to do and you're like well
yeah because maybe you don't know how to
use that correctly right like i think if
you
if you can tweak it and get it right and
that's really what grid is about and
lightning is
hey you don't have to be an expert now
you just drop it in there and like
it will probably work much better than
whatever your baseline is right
so that's what we're trying to do right
is bridge that gap and say hey i get it
like it is
look i don't discredit that because it
does take a lot to understand how to
train a neural network
and and like a random forest i don't
have to do anything i don't have to
tweak any hyper parameters they just
works right most of the time
um but a neural network you get one
hyper parameter wrong and you spend ten
thousand dollars in a month and you get
nowhere right
so i don't blame people for that but you
do you should know what you're doing
when you start using this stuff
if you know what you're doing you get
all the value if you don't then yeah
probably stick to the more traditional
models and
and simpler things um but there's a lot
of good tooling today that can help you
get there without you needing to be an
expert you know that's what lightning is
doing that's the greatest thing as well
got it awesome well um let's talk about
grid um
for a few minutes then um before we wrap
things up
um explain to us sort of the you know
you've sort of
um weaved in and out of some of the
things that that grid is doing around
pytorch but but what's the what's the
big vision there of the company
what are you trying to accomplish yeah i
mean so
so the focus of grid is really to help
people move really quickly
through their through the iteration
process right so
they want to try a bunch of things they
want to see how it works they have data
they want to use machine learning you
know not not even deep learning just
machine learning deep learning
um and they just want to try a bunch of
ideas as quickly as possible and see
what works and what doesn't work right
so grid is about that there is focus on
that specific use case right so
helping you get through those ideas as
fast as possible um
and we do that through giving you access
to like all the compute you need you
know
scaling up across as many machines as
you want um
not dealing with infrastructure just so
you can focus on the actual thing that
you're running
so it's about it's what lighting does
for
deep learning engineers and researchers
which is like abstract away all the
engineering so you just focus on the
math right um same thing here so machine
learning engineers data scientists
ai researchers you know research
scientists
anyone who wants to use data and wants
to use some sort of
machine learning model to get value of
that data that's what grid helps you do
is
scale that up right so that you can you
can move really fast through those ideas
so at the end of the day what i love to
see is that you know people do their
workflows on grid
they do everything they need there and
then when they're ready to go
you know they do whatever they want with
their models if that model gets
published great if it goes into a
production system great if it goes into
some sort of self-driving car great like
doesn't matter right but
um i think that we can streamline all
these processes so that
people get better at like the human
creativity part
and if i'm not mistaken you're starting
with the training
process right so you have a cloud-based
architecture that helps people train
models
at scale that's a i believe one of your
first offerings
exactly yeah so that's what you can do
today so you can come to grid
you know you can spin up all the
machines you want you can train whatever
you need
on there uh you can debug you can
prototype stuff
you can you know manage that at scale i
mean if you're
if you're training on your laptop like
you don't have a lot of issues but
if you're training like production
workloads um companies
even large academic data sets everything
there's a lot of stuff that goes into it
like how do you scale up you know
1000 models across each model across 12
gpus or
you know 32 gpus and get access to the
data quickly like there are so many
nuances that go into this and
you know it takes teams of people to
like really optimize this and
and you know we've been doing this for
forever like lightning we've been
solving these problems for
what like almost year and a half at this
point two years
most of that team has been you know both
sides of the production and research
world
so that's the the great team today is
helping you bring all that knowledge
again to go to a bigger scale
that's great you don't need like expert
engineers you just need
the data scientists and demo engineers
who just want to solve problems and like
you know use our tooling to to get that
done as fast as possible
and so the idea is to continue to sort
of expand on this
this notion this this key insight that
you had early on in the in the lightning
project
around separating um boilerplate code
glue code
um compute um all these other things
from the actual core
sort of inference um logic and and math
and algorithm itself is that is that
fair
yeah and we can i mean we can scale that
idea beyond that right so
these are things that will come over the
next few years via grid so
you know we have a very long road map
and yeah i hope you're all
part of it to see it come together but
yeah i mean the division is
much bigger than that and like you know
there we can apply this idea to many
things
so great where can people find out more
information if they want to get involved
yeah so we're close to early access
right now which means you go to a
website
grid ai grid dot ai you sign up
and then you know you'll get some email
saying hey you're on the wait list
and then uh you know we will allow you
on the products
as soon as there's a spot on the
waitlist comes available and then
you know you'll be able to do what you
need to do on there that's great
and if they say they're they're a friend
of pete or they heard about it on
um on dc thursday then you move them to
the top of the list right
yeah exactly great
awesome um well well this has been a
really fun chat um
your story is extraordinary um the way
you've wrangled the open source
community around lightning is really
awesome
um you know we're all dying to see what
happens with grid and
and track your success there um i just
wanted to ask you like a sort of a
parting shot um what's the what's the
hardest thing
about starting a company as a technical
person
yeah um i think it's
putting your engineering mentality away
um
when you know like i i still code
sometimes
but it's really like pulling away from
that right because if you're too deep in
the code
you can't really step out and like
holistically get the whole company to
align and run
right so as a founder and the ceo like
your job is to
align the company get everyone moving as
fast as possible towards a common goal
so if you're too too deep in the code
it's not going to happen so that's the
biggest challenge i think for engineers
is to
separate that and everyone will say this
to you and you'll blow them up for like
a year you'll say no i can go to
[Laughter]
yeah there's all the other softer things
right the the leadership skills
the people management and the recruiting
and the mark
there's there's all the things that you
have to do as a startup founder and
um you know we engineers are are
pretty self-confident in our ability to
kind of multitask and
um you know and all tap between things
but when it comes to a company with real
people and
um and you have to sort of know how to
express that vision and take the time to
do it it's a
it can be a little bit of a different
challenge for sure
yeah and i think also know your
strengths or weaknesses right like
you're bad at something
yeah know that so you can hire for that
yeah absolutely
well well um thanks again it's been been
great to have you on the show
and um we'll track the progress on grid
from
uh from here at data council thank you
for having me
so just a couple notes for the community
um before we sign off
make sure to join us next week on march
25th
we'll be diving into the analytics data
storage space and we'll have
venket who's the co-founder and ceo of
rockset which is a very interesting
company in the data analytics space
so don't miss that um don't forget to
subscribe and hit the bell
button so that you get notified when we
go live um in coming weeks
and remember you can find all of our
previous episodes of dc thursday
on the playlist here on youtube